david how are you doing did you meet
yeah
did you did you meet uh
you know once it comes to the concept
that you had
if you are in a battlefield combatant
with you know someone who's fighting
so you notice in self-defense that's the
concept
so different i mean if somebody advances
giving you the right
[Music]
which is wrong
um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the deen show which is a way
of life we try to put out there for
everyone to see
now wasn't that interesting uber driver
sheikh harim abu zaid my guest
no stranger to the dean show we have him
coming up here don't go anywhere that is
why god sent the final revelation
muhammad
god sent
the quran
to bring everybody back into one of
these
we believe in all of those as muslims
jesus and all of this we believe in all
the peoples they came from each
monotheism and muhammad is the same and
i'm inviting
the final messenger of god
how are
so tell us it's a unique experience
you're in the uber driver and now when
we get in there you talk about jihad
yeah
how did you open up initially
the conversation
uh
well i
i have to give you the credit because i
was busy with my phone
and
you know subhanallah he just reminded us
he reminded me with with a very special
moment that you know you can share islam
i'll take the quran okay there you go
beautiful that's the best choice yeah
it's in english yeah so that's the
meaning of the crown the originals in
the arabic unchanged campus-free temple
proof we have an international original
this is in english yeah and here i am
sitting and
you know
i just became my grandfather just
lies congratulations i was trying to
connect with my family but when i saw
your message please give him dawah
i started the conversation immediately
and i remembered you know subhanallah
sometimes just
being consumed with yourself is not
you know is not
fun
and i started the conversation where you
from and what do you do and
you know and uh
and then i i i told him listen the guy
who hired you
uh is preparing a gift for you
and then he said i mean i i have you
know i had to be true yeah
and then i i he said for what
i said that you listen to what i have to
say
i said go ahead
you know and then i started talking to
him about islam and
getting to the point but i sense from
his um you know
where he's from and and and so forth
that he's a christian and a devout one
uh he's from springfield missouri and i
i happen to live in in independence
missouri and i know the people there uh
they are you know devout so
we went into the concept of god because
that's you you would always hear me
saying this even in my lectures
uh that
you need to understand that jews and
christians believe in a god
but what they ended up doing they
distorted the concept of god and islam
came to correct that to rectify that
and and this is why uh eddie when the
prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam sent
uh
allah and the companion to yemen uh
hadith
the people who are living in yemen are
from the people of the book
let be the first thing that you talk to
them about we have actually multiple
wording one of these wording
let them know who god is
not to be the first thing not the first
not the third no fourth fifth number one
actually the other wording just to to be
clear
that they they they single out god in
their worship
now
once they obey you in this area then
talk to them about the five daily
prayers then talk to them about the alms
giving charity zakah so
and and this is i consider it to be one
of the obstacles of da'wah in america
by muslims i mean one of the things that
because not many muslims um you know i'm
not trying to brace myself here but not
many muslims know how to speak about
allah
in in a way that is because we're very
disciplined when we talk about allah
subhana wa
we cannot
we cannot
name allah with a name that he did not
name himself with
we cannot attribute something that allah
did not attribute to himself subhana
that is why the the the rule
the
that you must have
uh an authentic evidence meaning from
the quran or sound hadith
that talks about god talks about allah
subhana wa for you to talk about allah
you can't make up your own things he
can't yes
like we always say you have not seen god
and no one can
no one is created looks like god or
equals to god once it comes to his
qualities his attributes his names
and number three no one else went and
saw god and and come and and described
you uh how god looks like so you have to
rely on the revelation that is why allah
subhanahu wa said in the verse uh ayat
will crusade known by the verse of the
footstool or or that
and we have no access to anything about
allah except what he will and what he
willed is the revolution
is the revelation
you know we we engaged in this then you
know i guess we're getting closer to uh
arriving at our destination and he
wanted to
uh you know uh basically uh give it to
me and he brought up the subject of
jihad that's a big one with a lot of
people it isn't it is but it's it's very
easy to refute yeah i mean it's it's
it's a piece of cake
you know um
first of all the word you had you have
to explain it that
literally
in in english you had means to strive
and the first place you're supposed to
strive against is yourself to submit
that you strive to wake up for fajr you
strive to
be a good person you strive to be a
servant to humanity
you strive against the whispers of satan
you strive against the people the human
who are trying to with the word striving
with the word and and once we say the
word kind words you know the the the
field of dawah and so forth
um after that you know you uh if if you
are attacked
uh you know and then you are to defend
yourself and and and and you had jihad
here is the the bottom line uh eddie
once it comes to jihad jihad is a
declared battle between two
fighting factions
okay
everybody knows
that you know we are on to one another
you're trying to kill me i'm trying to
kill you that's a declared that that's
what it is but you know it has nothing
to do with what that's battlefield in
context yes
one of the great scholars
he listed about 13
different uh
forms of jihad and he was uh yeah
you know you know specific i'm talking
about yeah yeah
yeah and then one of them was what
you're talking about then he went and
listed all the other ones that like i
mean doing what what a person
yeah did you have to go over that please
that you had again it's yourself yeah we
know that inside us there is the evil
side and there is the good side one of
there is a wicked part
and there is a good part
i'm striving to enhance the good part
against the wicked part so that's
actually the first area and and that
particular jihad by the way uh uh you
know that struggle or against yourself
is the most important of them all as a
matter of fact to the extent that some
people actually attribute a weak hadith
to the prophet sallallahu alaihi it's
not authentic but the meaning is correct
yeah that when he was returning from the
final battle he uh
participated in is called tabuk he
actually said to his companions he
didn't say that the the chain of
transmitters uh
is weak weak hadith is not but the the
meaning sometimes it's a weak but the
meaning is is correct that the meaning
is is encrypted in the revelation he
said we came from the minor jihad to the
the the major jihad
uh what is the major jihadist messenger
of allah is
striving against that's a big one that's
that's huge and there is that the strive
that the striving and the struggle again
is satan you know the jinn the whispers
we we get attacked by these whispers
that's another jihad
you have that you had again is the
hypocrites the people the human
team you know who are around you your
bad friends the people that trying to
hang around you and trying to get them
get you to their ways and and you're
struggling saying no you know that's not
my my path i don't want to do that i
want to go to the other side that's
another because they they normally come
and tempt you they normally come and
give you that company and sometimes they
they hit you in the right area and then
that you had against the hypocrites you
know in a muslim community i mean you
know when you have a community because
he cannot accuse another muslim who says
allah with hypocrisy yeah you can't say
that person is ah you can't say that
you have to be basically deal with them
the prophet
salallahu he was told through revelation
who are the hypocrites
in his community yet he did not treat
them on what he knew from allah but he
treated them on one on their action on
what they do
[Music]
the basic rule in islam that you deal
with a person based on what you see
based on what what they say based on
what
they do and and your act accordingly but
what they hide in their chest that's
between them and allah the prophet said
to one of his companions who was certain
that this person is a hypocrite he said
i was not commanded to
open up the chest of people in order to
figure out what they have inside so now
you have to strive against that person
in a very interesting way you have to
protect immune yourself against his
tricks against him another form of jihad
another form of jihad there is not now
another
form of jihad which is that you had
against the kafir but now not with the
weapon but the kafir who tries what to
cast misconceptions and doubts about
your religion now you have to use the
word and actually allah described that
form of jed which is
giving
imagine this in surat al-farqaan and
strive using the quran using the kalima
using the revelation to
weigh jihad against them which is dawa
you see once you give you see
this guy you know you saw him and
uh you know he could say some things to
trigger your anger
you're supposed what to control yourself
you see that the final form of jihad
which will you know the one that is
actually people think it's the one and
only
is you know you're supposed to be
furious you're supposed to be angry but
you know this guy said couple of words
to me that got me upset
but you see when you're giving dawah
with the tongue you can't you have to be
what
cool you have to control what your nafs
that's why it's a major jihad because it
takes self-control that you don't get
upset you try to maintain a good nice
tone kindness because that's how you
attract those people to islam then comes
in the final form which is in the
battlefield i mean look at the geneva
convention is is a self-defense got
given right but overall you know because
we have two types of jihad you had the
defending
but
overall it's a declared battlefield but
look at the etiquettes look at the
etiquettes the prophet
when he would uh you know
advise the the army and the leader of
the army don't kill a woman don't kill a
child don't burn a tree
don't kill um you know a monk in his
sanctuary
um
you understand don't take down a tree
unless they use that tree to you know to
as as a means to fight you you know so
this is what the geneva convention
the rules of engagement and and and this
is in a declared war but there is no way
and this is where he's hinting to there
is no way that you go and blow some
people off
uh in order to make a point you can do
that in islam that's random killing no
no no no so you cleared that
misconception that he had yeah he said a
nice guy he was asking some genuine
question he seemed like he was searching
it was like that was and we'll get into
that later it was like
it was like meant he was at where he
needed to be at the right place right
time to hear the message i told him i
told him the same exact
text is in the old testament
if you open the torah it's filled with
battles and fighting
you see islam has been always a way of
life
islam teaches you how to relieve
yourself
imagine this islam is not going to teach
you how to engage
in a battle with someone else yeah
that that the cost of it is lives yeah
you know so islam is going to teach you
the etiquette
when do you have a justified reason
cause to do it to begin with and how you
you go about it that's how islam is
islam teaches us how to marry how to
have a relationship with your spouse
islam is a way of life so even those
rules of engagement you usually ask
people would you rather have no rules or
some rules
so it breaks down the rules yeah yeah
that's and these are divine rules you
know and they always exist now you're
you're actually you're a director of
religious affairs because we're talking
about quran hadith and you mentioned
some things so just for our our audience
um
uh you who haven't seen you before
you're also um the imam head imam at the
colorado mcc muslim community centers is
right yeah alhamdulillah i'm you know
i hate to use the word founder but we
started this organization director
founder yeah an imam head mufti molana
phd candidate uh
i wouldn't say hit move to you
and all that so you're you're also a phd
candidate or i have a very good title
yeah that i love what's that a student
of law student of knowledge that's it
yeah just leave it but for the record
technically so you're uh this was from
before phd candidate you're a doctor now
of the uh islamic studies of quran
hadith sciences at the at the american
open university office of the quran i
think this is important because when
when when you mention a hadith or
something and someone's like well who's
this guy they might have been quoting
that hadith for so long so now like who
is he to say that okay so then we just
put down some credentials just ask them
to verify yeah the yeah so it seems like
you know what you're talking about
you've been uh you got some uh some time
put in here to learn in islam and i hope
so helps
a lot okay so so from there uh this is
great you're having a nice casual
conversation uh this is a responsibility
on every muslim to share it's not our
duty to to convert anybody but to just
share the message talking of this
project um
[Music]
you know the colorado uh muslims
community center
um we we actually started this project
with a very uh uh good uh uh step which
is the revival of the concept of
endowment
you know what endowment what that you
buy a business
in order to sustain your operation
because you know a lot of muslim
organization they rely on fundraising
and and normally it would limit your so
we ended up
purchasing this plaza just to tell you
the piece that um why i'm bringing this
up
and
amazing one of uh once we purchased the
plastic there was a guy who was working
for the previous owner
tony his name or anthony something like
that i hope i can remember his name
so we decided to keep him he was a
christian
you know all my time i'm saying you know
what i have a lot of time to give dawah
to this guy
he's working for us
you know i'm going to see him
and i never attempted and by the way
when
eddie very important because a lot of
muslims didn't realize this giving dawah
that he actually asked them to become
muslims
you explain to them
what islam is especially once it comes
to tawheed monotheism then he actually
prompted them to accept islam because a
lot of people say oh i'm giving him dao
a lot of these people don't know what
are you asking them to do yeah you
understand so i i was giving him bits
and pieces relying on the fact that this
guy is staying with us
one day i'm sitting in my house and i
received a phone call he got a heart
attack and he died
he's 40 something years old
so you think you got more time but you
never know no you never know yeah that
could be the only time this guy will be
exposed to islam and muslims and you are
the opportunity for him to hear the mess
listen
we're not in the business of converting
people this is why i say it it's wrong
to say how many people you converted
there is no such a thing
and he asked me this question he said
well knowledge i said listen it has
nothing to do with that it has something
to do with allah turning
your heart on yes to accept what i'm
saying
and this has to do with what's inside
your heart because allah deals with your
hearts
you understand so we're in the business
of what establishing the evidence
against the people that listen you heard
the message of islam from this guy
whom you given a ride
to the deen show
what happened why he didn't accept it
and so so he established the evidence
against the people whether they accept
it or not it's between them and allah
subhanahu wa time and that's what we
attempted at the end and subhanallah and
you know hopefully it will happen later
inshallah i mean that's the best
investment i mean that's something that
will carry on even if the person doesn't
accept they reject but you initiated you
fulfilled your obligation and that's
huge with allah isn't it i mean that's
something that doesn't go unrecorded
look what allah says in the quran
if allah wills he will make everyone
believe
but allah giving us the human being
the freedom to choose
that is why
you cannot force people to accept islam
you can technically it can't happen
because it it defeats its its purpose
now my job and your job is to convey in
your mission is to convey and that's
what muslims need to understand but now
convey with the invitation
so convey with the invitation so after
you convey come on would you like to
become a muslim that's what it takes to
become a muslim come
because a lot of brothers they do that a
lot of sisters they do that especially
the professionals but they don't take
that step
come on would you like to come to the
masjid and i mean listen
you can't force them you can but you
need to take that extra step to invite
them
call people to the path of allah you
have to do that at one stage what
brought you to islam i mean maybe before
you got all these degrees all these
degree these degrees and whatnot i mean
there was a point at what point did you
determine
yeah but uh at what points did you
decide because everyone
and that's one thing people even they
we're all born uh as we say on the
fitrah you know submissive to the
creator then the soul you know gets uh
tempted by the little things out there
and whatnot and then a person has to
come to the realization at one point is
this the truth because a lot of people
are going through the rituals but at one
point and some people think oh this is
inherited you know what i mean so i'm
just going to go through the rituals
they really truly haven't submitted i'm
sure you come across people like this at
what point in your life did you realize
this is the truth from the creator
because then you probably go through the
the thoughts like how do i not know how
do i know that christianity is not the
way how do i know buddhism not the way
there's all these different religions
and then a person has some self-doubt
but at one point did you come to know
that indeed this is from the creator and
there is no doubt about it
when i hear a long story then
in short a condensed version
well
um because people look at you now and
they say okay maybe i can't achieve that
i can't get to where he's at he's an
imam he's the person you know you guys
send people give like some other clergy
they free people from the hellfire and
or and give them give them paradise are
you those guys oh you don't do that
you know i just want to tell you this um
uh
a lot of people don't know this about me
and this is so this is amazing now i'm
gonna open up originally i used to be a
tour guide
in egypt
you know some guy who takes tourists
around and you know and and showed him
the pyramids this is the pyramids was
built yeah
and uh you know normally the main
business for a tour guide is to sell
gold
cartoon you know uh
hieroglyphic
writing because we make a lot of
commission you know a lot of so for you
to sell it you have to wear gold and you
know or you were all like jewelleried up
oh yeah
so
i speak german too so we ended up with
that group coming from germany
and don't feel bad because a couple few
weeks ago i had a share also a sheikh
abdullah he used to have gold teeth in
his mouth
let me just finish
so
they requested to meet a famous uh clerk
he passed away may allah have mercy on
him his name is muhammad ali
i don't know if you heard that anymore
he excelled in the field of tafsir
once it comes to the names and the
attributes in particular
but
i had very high regard for this year
because
i used to hear him all the time i i just
used to love him
dearly
so finally i'm getting this opportunity
to actually go sit in front of him
the group requested to meet with him as
a non-muslim group in order to ask him
questions about islam
so
i said man i get
of course i assume that i will be the
guy to translate the conversation
between because he speaks arabic
but then i called and i found out that
he has his own interpreter he doesn't
trust anyone else smart yeah but because
it's really correct because you know
religious vocabularies are totally
different to uh touristic and and
historian you know history of a couple
of this so in illinois
i said okay i'm just gonna go sit in
front of him
so i went and i sat in front of the
group so normally he would speak in
arabic and this his interpreter would
translate
so i'm sitting in front of him
and as he's talking in arabic
i'm doing like i'm nodding
you know i'm i'm agreeing with him i'm
loving it i'm
you know i'm really loving it you know
he thought that i'm german because of
the way i look
you know i had gel in my hair and
a flowery kind of shirt and i opened my
chest you know yeah showing the the
chest with the gold were you submitting
at that time
no so you hadn't come fully to islam no
okay so that's what i think
you opened up a can of phones here so
that's fine yeah
so then i kept nodding so he was very
surprised
to assume that a german
is a jerk well he assumed that yeah
then he asked me do you understand what
i'm saying
because i am nothing i said
sheikh yes
i do
are you a muslim
my son are you a muslim
i said yes
why what are you doing to yourself
in a very fatherly way
just to show you that subhanallah
like a concern like a loving way a
loving way
like he's worried about i can see your
facial expression why why are you doing
this to yourself my son
you know
why in the muslim why are you doing this
looking like elvis presley or somebody
yes
that word you know changed me
i actually
i i i remember this i memorized the
quran in 13 months
you know how old were you at that time i
was in my late 20s you know and and
and
you know just to show you
you know
how that one is through softness and and
yeah there's hope for everyone i mean
look at that i mean that connects more
now people can probably relate to you
more because there's a lot of people
following that way you want to hear
something so funny sure so i was in
america i came to america
and then i started learning and
memorizing and all that learning the
team
so i
started having a beard
so when you arrive at the cairo airport
the people with the beer they normally
take them to a special place to you know
check them out and so forth
so the guy from the like what equals the
cia in egypt there i was sitting out
there what's your name
because he has no record for me out
there you know for for them i'm i'm the
ideal citizen you know i'm
a touristic guy and i'm somebody who's
you know who's into that world i mean
the guy wears gold and that's the modern
citizen that we want
so what is your name my name is karim
so i was eight
where you graduate
where did you graduate from oh faculty
of tourism and
hotel business
then he asked me
what are you doing to yourself
now he's telling me the opposite with
the shaykh said what do you do
and these are see these are muslims also
muslims you see so instead of the same
exact line that the sheikh used but of
course he used it in a uh authoritarian
kind of yeah you know
you know he used it
why did you do this to yourself you're
having a beard you look like a muslim
now why are you doing this to yourself
has the people asking you have they
truly submitted to the creator well they
are doing their job
but just to show you how
so subhan allah he immediately got me to
recall that same sentence
so that sentence changed me
now i'm being tested will you change
back the same sentence and alhamdulillah
i'm still here and i'm making dua that i
continue
this is wonderful to hear i mean i think
people hear this uh especially people
who are kind of going through the same
struggles and they look at you and they
can relate right you don't see somebody
too far far away from them yeah
so back to what i said are you the
what's the difference between um you got
clergy uh you guys people who who sent
just oh these are the guys some people
think oh you just send people to
hellfire give them peridot i mean
what authority do you have now as a
muslim clergy can you send people can
you give people a one-way ticket to the
hellfire i can't i can't even do that to
myself
even though we believe as muslims that
the prophet salallahu himself
will will be the first one
who will
hold the you know the the the doors of
jannah before anyone else but yet he
said to us i don't know
he said
rasulullah
hadith
one of the companions one of his
disciples passed away in the early
stages in medina
so as they were preparing him for burial
so one of the female companions praised
him
he said
basically she's saying that he's going
to jannah
then he looked at her and he said why
you drink how do you know wallahi
rasulullah by allah i am the
and i don't know what allah will do with
me what does this teach us that teaches
us that there is no such a thing in
islam you know
that teaches us to live between fear and
hope
fear always from going astray
uh but the fear which does not send you
to despair the fear that gets you
uh out of trouble keeps you away from
the nightclubs uh yes
but at the same time when you engage in
the obedience hope now you know hope
that allah and and and this is
you mentioned his name he's one of the
people who excelled in that field he
said
you know a believer flies back to allah
with his heart with two wings the wing
of fear and the wing of hope
while you're healthy we'll off
let the wing of fear go up a little bit
you know but when you
khalas you're about to die then the wing
of hope should be up is the head the
love the head the love yes the head is
the driving force love yes loving allah
subhanahu wa yeah because many many
people who don't understand islam they
try to use that they um against islam
that god almighty allah is not a god of
love no the head is the love yeah
you see but you must have the three
together
christians were christians you know
worship allah through the love
love yeah but but for you to love allah
you must know his names and attributes
yes and this is why it's a key
you know
has a very profound statement he said
if you know allah through his names
attributes and actions
you will find your hearts come bill to
love allah
and and and that's what makes the
difference you know that
his name is the most loving the most
merciful the compassionate the just all
these are how we get to know the fear
the wise
the provider you know the the
latif
how he delivers you in a very detailed
oriented way you know
i'm actually this those two days in
chicago i'm spending uh
and the names and the attributes i'm
going to be talking about that's my
favorite subject i love this subject now
you've actually had some speaking about
trinity crucifixion you've actually done
some debates so yeah you're very well
versed also in the bible and you've uh
how what did you gain from those debates
you had some debates with some christian
pastors on who is jesus
and did paul create christianity the
crucifixion what did you take out of
those from that experience that you
gained from that and tell us a little
about those debates that you had
one of
the main points
that muslims need to realize
that we're very disciplined
once we speak about allah and i think i
said that already but yeah let me give
it to you now in a context of debate
i was debating with this and that debate
is almost two and a half hours available
in youtube somewhere in
the divinity of jesus yes who is jesus
by zayd uh sheikh kareem abu zaid that
you go watch it yeah
now
we have one verse in the quran in a
chapter called
that kills that subject kills it means
finishes it you know once and for all
the verse says
is a messenger who came in chains of
messengers in a chain of messengers
meaning he is in sequence in his own
sequence
and his mother
mariam
peace be upon her peace be on jesus
peace be upon all of the messengers of
allah
she was a truthful woman
here it is here's the point of reference
they used to eat food
so as i'm debating you know i i said to
the the priest um that listen if they
eat food that means what they need to do
what of course the verse doesn't
indicate that but
you know
you know
it's blasphemous to say this about allah
subhana wa and that's why but that's a
profound example that
you're giving yeah it's it's an example
you see that i kind of extended the
meaning a little bit because if you eat
that means you need to go to the
bathroom yeah it means you're dependent
on food you're weak you're yeah
you know one of one of the one of the
bounties of gender that we don't go to
the bathroom exactly you know one of the
blessings in general that you eat and
drink but yet you don't
go and relieve yourself
so
you know i told him you want to tell me
that god
does that
come on what are you saying so here is
daddy butthole
he comes back and he says well
imam kareem has an issue with god and
i'm sorry this is blasphemous to say
that but
we have a rule
that says the one who conveys the
statement of people
which is
this believing statement doesn't make me
that yeah you know he said imam kareem
has a problem with
god eating and taking a leak
what is wrong with god taking a leak
you see
i i went back and i said that's the
difference
between us and you
islam were very disciplined once this
week you see
was asked by allah to say this
and he tells me that he has a son
i will be the first to worship yeah but
he never told me that
he told me that he does not need have
you understand so that's
really the core the key the the other
thing that i learned so much
from uh from these debates from these
debates
is going through history how history
explains to you
how
people can twist and change
the religion of allah
i became so fascinated
with the
character in christianity and the
negative sense actually not in the
positive sense called paul
or soul
this is the 13th
self-claimed disciple
he is someone who never met jesus in his
life actually he was in the business of
killing prophet jesus uh followers and
disciples he was like a bounty hunter
yes yeah and he ends up with that you
know
experience which you know extreme sufis
would i mean with all due respect to
them would you know it would say that i
saw light and all that stuff you know
you know these and and and this guy goes
into europe
and he breaches basically a religion of
of the liking
opposite to what opposite to what jesus
brought at one stage
he was invited by the true disciples of
jesus to come to jerusalem
and he was chased out
actually this is in their literature
he was actually one of the disciples
called barnaba he held him out
because they they wouldn't agree with
his religion
and and now this guy spread all these
false teachings about christianity which
is being followed now
for years and then he
developed followers after him then the
year 318 came in than i see whatever
and the imperial powers came in order to
enforce
that pauline theology and cancel out the
the theology or or the the the actual
teachings of the disciples and actually
burn and kill people who advocate for
this
subhanallah i truly believe that this is
what they're trying to do with islam
right now they are trying to create
american islam western islam
uh islam that works with the west
and that's where muslims need to be very
careful but insha allah it will never
happen because of one single fact
that the religion of islam is preserved
in the chests
people memorizing it
in writing
in writing the quran is there the hadith
of the prophet salallahu is there the
truth is there but these guys they
burned the books they burned the the the
the emperor
you know ruled that the imperial he uses
imperial power actually to he put to the
cross through followers of jesus you
need to understand that he
he buried burned
all these literature that talks about
monotheism and talks about jesus being
the messenger of allah
and and he only enhanced the pauline
theology but with us it's not going to
work with islam i just need to let
people know let the world know it's not
going to work why because our religion
is preserved is protected in the chest
in writing and also in action
there will always be
some of my um
they will never be
you know hurt
by people leading them
by being let down by people or or
disgraced by people
and they will stay like this until
prophet jesus peace be upon him descends
again and and he will wipe his over over
their heads we ask allah that we are of
them
and for our for our christian friends
out there who
when they hear us talk about this i mean
it's obviously i mean well-intentioned
we uh we're giving some many of these
facts that christian historians bible uh
scholars that i've also had on a show
they bring these facts to light and it's
interesting when you mention that
because we don't say anything
disparaging about jesus i mean we you
can't be a muslim unless you love jesus
as one of the mightiest messengers you
know just like moses abraham they all
brought the same message worship the
creator not the creation but it's
interesting since we're talking about
history when you when you do when you
look into that history
you see like the ebonites you see um
yeah areas you see these uh these
original true followers of jesus they
didn't believe in what we what what is
commonly believed in today they believed
in monotheism one god there is something
very interesting uh you know you brought
the the areas yes
when the prophet
the good-looking companion that jibril
would actually come in his form yes as a
messenger to caesar
you know what one of the things that he
said to him
become a muslim
if you don't you will bear the sin of
the arias
he said that yes
what is meant by that
he's talking about the true
followers of jesus
who were persecuted for their monotheism
because the brand of christianity you're
following is the
distorted one so you had those original
yes true followers of pure monotheism
they were persecuted their history a lot
of it is lost yeah no it's difficult
it's there it's there but imagine how
much is lost and burned because now when
it comes over as a government
um
constantine accepting this modern-day
christianity they like you said
persecuted even more so all of these
other opposing fractions it's very
dangerous when the state
uses its power to enforce certain and
this happened in islam by the way i
don't know if you go back into history
the people who who worship their brain
their intellect
you know the people who spoke of that
the quran was created
what really got their math
promoted and circulating and
unfortunately some muslims right now
they follow them unknowingly you know
why because the imperial because of the
the state you know the state got
involved and the state would punish
anyone who would believe otherwise
that's why imam ahmad was
jailed because he did not say the quran
so when you know when you get the state
and and this is unfortunately
what some countries right now are trying
to do with islam
but it will never succeed and i say it
with a smile it will never succeed
because this is the final revelation
it has to be a
changeable
yeah and if you're looking for it allah
will guide you to it so now wrapping up
with this point we love jesus you cannot
be you can actually
find yourself in the hell fire as a
muslim if you deny jesus if you don't
believe in him as a mighty messenger is
this correct
man i love jesus with all my heart
with all my senses but here it is
i love him the way that allah wants me
to love him
but that love
will never
places him ahead of allah
because
his love
is a branch of the love of allah
you understand
i love the messenger of allah muhammad
because of the love of allah
and i love you as well because you love
allah
so
everything and that's what's called
even this is very if you you can talk
about that anymore now but
you know that you know these words are
but that's it you know that
i fully why sometimes you meet a muslim
and you don't even know his name and you
love the guy
because who makes you love that person
allah you know because
you know like i always say you love with
your heart and the heart is in the hands
of allah and allah will direct a heart
to love another person because that
person is good with allah
let's just clarify this point this word
for people tuning in and they
might have heard this name for the first
time allah what do you tell christians
kind of to just
alleviate any of their apprehensions
because they're used to saying and i
think this is
this is something that's so powerful
because people are using the word god
they don't even have the proper name of
of the creator god didn't even exist
this name didn't even exist the english
language didn't even exist you know when
i say god when i say allah i mean god
with a capital g god with a capital g
yeah is this the god that jesus called
upon yeah allah you know how are the so
elohim
well needless to say that we don't have
to go deep just so they know that this
is i'll throw something at them and they
will realize what i'm trying to say we
have christian arabs yeah arab
christians and arab jews
we have actually you know
and the old and new testaments
are available in arabic
imagine the first page in the book of
genesis you will find allah
repeated 17 times
in reference to what
god with a capital g yeah so that's it
yes uh going back uh to the uber drive
and our responsibility of dawa i myself
i try to i make dua myself and say ya
allah give me an opening or i can share
because if you care you share so i was
uh and this goes back to what we're
saying allah
and connecting connecting it back to
something people can relate so make a
long story short i'm in the uber and the
uber gives you like the name of the
person i see the person next to me you
come in and he's blasting the music
having a good time it's like he's uh
really enjoying it but i see he's got
what would be an arabic name i i'm
connecting it to him being muslim and
then there's a person in the back
so as we're driving i'm almost at my
stop
and then the
person sneezes
and the and the person the back says god
bless you i said oh god bless you that's
an opening
so then i asked the person who's driving
i said how do you say
i know how he's going to respond say how
do you say god bless you in your
language he says alhamdulillah
i said have you ever heard this word
alhamdulillah
she said no and i said then i started to
connect it back i said you know that
jesus you know you know jesus yeah i
know jesus so i said you know jesus said
alhamdulillah and i was like
she was like no and then i connected it
back to do you remember
i'm sure you remember this verse in the
bible where it says um when a person
came to jesus in the gospel matthew i
believe it was and he says oh good
master
what good thing can i do that i may have
eternal life yeah
yeah and he said why are you calling me
good yeah there's only one good but god
it's he's basically saying alhamdulillah
it's like someone diverting the
attention from you to god and then i
also explained
allahu akbar
you know when he said the father is
greater than i the father is greater
than all because he's pretty much saying
allahu akbar and then we got into tahit
and and the pure monotheism the muslims
face he was muslim he was so excited to
talk about you know we cleared up some
misconception and it was beautiful so we
were relating back things back to god to
jesus and going back to what you were
saying in these explicit verses jesus is
saying alhamdulillah diverting attention
from him to allah he's saying
god almighty is the greatest i want to
tell you something yeah
but you know i i i like the way that you
you know i think you need to come up
with some techniques and how to open up
a conversation
on religion you know you know and i'm
i'm so blessed that you reminded me you
know when i was coming to you today
um
because sometimes really we forget why
we're here yeah and you don't want to
feel like you you it's very difficult to
open up and you're the weird guy now
the weird religious guy while you're
here but let me get to the the point i'm
trying to make here is
and i say it with confidence
if you actually approach
the existing
new testament
without any preconceived notions
about jesus about trinity just clear
yourself out completely yes
you will reach the truth there
the bible will lead you
to islam
the lord's prayer
what about the lord's prayer you see if
you put al-fatiha next to the lord's
it's there it's there islam is there
islam is there yes they did some
distortion yeah the quran says that we
we don't question that
but the truth is still there the truth
still there and it should lead you to
the quran and the
final messenger salallahu said
we're having some fun here we're asking
some very important questions
why not get some other people involved
we have a few questions here we promise
to get
answered
and let me ask you
[Music]
i was surprised this one didn't come up
how would you explain to someone who
asked you about sharia law
i think we covered it when we were uh
did he ask you that in the in the no no
well you know
we covered it uh islam is a way of life
you know what before you continue i just
had this week's program a a sheikh bilal
and he mentioned you can maybe take it
from here that sharia
uh is mentioned in the bible over 250
times
is that correct
in the bible yeah yes i mean
we actually believe that prophet jesus
when he returns as muslims
you know
he will implement the sharia
you know he will lament the divine law
and that's why there will be will be a
blessing i think in simple words you
should let those people know
the religion of islam is a way of life
that concept of separation that you go
to
a mosque and you're devout and then you
come out you're a different person
that's not islamic at all you're a
muslim in the bathroom you're a muslim
in the bedroom you're a muslim
in the battlefield you're a muslim so
you're conscious of your creator at all
times yes yes there's not a time out now
and and
and and look at the the the we have
something in islam called holistic
objectives
or
the holistic aims
of sharia
look the sharia is tuned to protect
number one protect the religion
individual religion that you're free to
believe
christians jews jews
stop there
two
this is if you have right now by the way
you can't force people you can't do
nothing but you know in an established
uh islamic freedom of religion yes
so this is number one number two the
protection of the human life
that's sharia now protecting human life
yes the sanctity
of the human life and we we don't say
the muslim life the human life human
life the human life
three the protection of the progeny
the honor the lineage
that's why the institution of marriage
no adultery
children who come into this world are
entitled to be born
into a house where there is a father and
a mother committed to the course
not a boyfriend someone reads a
translation and i and he says okay xena
adultery so that means i can have i'm
not committing adultery i am uh because
that's what it's translated is that but
i have a girlfriend
i mean
so so not everything a promiscuity
illicit relationship outside of marriage
yes okay
because shaytan plays with people's mind
this is what this is actually what
happens yeah well the prophet said that
time will come when some of my ummah
will make halal yeah alhera
for men
alcohol they call it spiritual drinks or
medical marijuana we have medical
marijuana
well as if instrument music you know
they will make it halal but let me let
me don't lose your place you you
mentioned something uh uh
you have okay uh marijuana and i've done
programs on this that uh obviously
that's not allowed in islam and all that
but now with the new research coming up
i'm just asking you for not because
often you think of someone smoking
getting high but if they're taking an
extract from the cannabioids and making
it exactly interact is different yes
that's what i'm saying and an oil so
they have oil it's a medicinal effect
yeah all the medications come from opium
and we know this okay so that's what i'm
saying that's different extract yeah
that's different but it's in original
form when you smoke and no no no no no
no
no
come on yeah
give me a break no no no okay so we go
back to the the the
the sharia the holistic aim the
protection of the religion the
protection of the human life the
protection of the
uh progeny
that is why islam says no l s b g d d d
whatever you know i don't know how many
are there
uh homosexual no because a man and a man
is is going to kill the human race
imagine if every may allah protect us
but hypothetical here imagine a man and
a man a woman and a woman that's what
the people decide to do
that means are we going to have more
kids born into this world no so the
protection of the progeny and this is
what you just said this is in line with
christians and jews this is the same
thing that husband and wife
we call it music law
then the protection of the intellect
that is why drinking is no
you know
imagine area and i read this recently
that almost 80 000
deaths in the united states of america
are caused by drunk driving
wow
a year
can you imagine i mean i'm that problem
number's probably bigger that's that's
i'm an american you know
i mean
this makes any difference i feel jealous
for my country
but imagine now if a foreign force
attacks america
and they kill 80 thousand what will they
do
eighty thousand from alcohol and but the
person says hey in moderation
finally the protection of the individual
property yeah you work and i come and i
take it steal it no
so that's it that's what they refer to
that's where the these criminal
punishments in islam
uh the execution of the killed that
listen we have other avenues the
previous sharia as previous law did not
give ransom as an option you can
actually ransom if the person forgives
me forgives you
you can be forgiven and so forth but
these are the
crimes or the criminal punishments in
islam which they think it's exclusive
sharia that they you know
uh sharia is only these uh criminal
punishments the cutting of the hand the
flogging and all that stuff no but
normally if you look into a crime
i'm sorry into a punishment
not in association with the crime you're
going to end up with a bias judgment
yeah what is the the penal code is what
about one percent of the whole there's
like 600
600 236 versus even one percent not even
one percent even one percent but they
focus the they
hate provocateurs they focus on the
lessons exactly like jihad
we how many how many types of jihad did
we list
how many times many yeah you mentioned
that you mentioned 13 13 yeah we
mentioned at least four or five yeah
right in our but they focus on but they
focus on what what suits what suits and
that's the danger that's why we need the
din show that's why we need more
channels to teach people because they
are the one who dictate these concepts
they create them they promote them they
you see the problem i call them the
white version of isis yeah
you see they end up identifying what
islam is to to the people yeah and
meanwhile we're sitting out there and
doing nothing about it so you list some
beautiful points people can also go and
to get more of an elaborate academic uh
longer explanation you also have a talk
on shadia they can put your name yeah i
have a five-part series
so just in short um so now we connected
it back to jesus moses they all brought
the same thing islam sharia same thing
this is uh
the injunctions by the creator if you
aren't comfortable with your own
knowledge in islam are you still
eligible
to give dawah this is uh from a question
you're asking
you're not comfortable with your
knowledge are you still obligated to
give up
after he completed the religion
and he delivered the final dayan we call
it the the scholars they call it
the farewell sermon
he said to his companions
he asked them this question in the day
of judgment you will be asked about me
that's what he meant what will you say
he said we bear witness that you have
completed
you have perfected
you have explained
you you delivered oh messenger
imagine he's addressing his companions
now he's telling them
please convey
after me
even if it is one verse
so it is the responsibility
of every living muslim especially in the
west every living alive muslim
that is yours
in the west
that you convey at least one verse share
and
what is the easiest verse which every
muslim i bet you if betting is
in a halal way
memorize
who
say say he is allah the one say he is
god the one and only is that pure
monotheism is that
is that
that's simple is that
and like we said in america in the west
talking to christian and jews and i
shared the hadith with you you can't
leave that you can't ignore that you're
wasting your time yes you can go and
talk about oh the sharia and that don't
engage in this you see we get engaged
into these conversations because we have
to they
throw it at you and you have to respond
but you know this is the least that you
can convey so you cannot use
uh lack of knowledge
uh as an excuse not to give dawah yeah
can you comment on this this story about
ibrahim he was in the fire
the frog was coming and just taking some
water and spitting into the fire trying
to put it out signifying you know
that
what is that frog going to do
with that little bit of flour so it was
his
motivation
the little that he can do he did first
of all this is israelites israel okay we
don't believe it wouldn't be light yeah
but it's okay but it's a powerful
example right but can i give you
something that is go ahead please more
authentic yeah you know
is that does the story uh well it's a
what's it yet yeah right we have a lot
of things like that we know
yeah this is right but let's get to the
point yeah
um
so how would you use something like that
do you mention it's israelia and then
use it to you can tell it yeah you can
tell you see we have a rule regarding
israelites which are not authentic
because there are israelites
first of all what israelites mean what
uh basically uh references from the
people of the book gotcha from the uh
you know that's coming to us from uh
whether schoolers or or people who used
to be christian on jews and accepted
islam like
yes people throughout history they are
very well versed in christianity and
judaism and when they join islam they
bring in that information now the
prophet salallahu said that if they talk
to you do not believe them do not belie
them yeah
but talk about it as long as it's not
contradictory yeah to our religion and
here this kind of goes with the means
taking the means that you have right the
frog only had that means but when you
have an you know more authentic give me
yeah you shouldn't you know i mean this
is
again i'm not that's why i'm coming to
you yeah you see i'm i'm a tough guy
yeah i got one more for you i'll watch
you after you finish this one no hard
feelings not at all leave this please no
no okay
there is
a beautiful
rasulullah
says
if you see the hour
the signs of the hour
the judgment day happening
and in your hand you have a baby bomb
tree yeah date palm tree
plant it
do something
imagine you're dying
the the world is collapsing around you
and you have a boundary and he chose
fasila that's the word he was a baby
bomb tree because we know bound trees
date palm trees it takes normally seven
eight years until it actually what
produces do something
do something give dawah do something
without you
okay so the story goes like this
that a lady came to moses peace be upon
him
and she had
committed adultery
had the baby killed the baby
so then he sent her off
this is how the story goes
and then gibril came
and said why did you do that she came
for forgiveness he goes
didn't you hear what she said what she
did
you know so he told her to get out of
here before the brimstones come down and
were all
destroyed and then gibril
he said do you know who's worse than her
and he said who can be worse the one who
doesn't pray
have you heard this story
again it's a sci-fi yes
i think it's one of the israelites yeah
but it's powerful if you think about it
it is powerful yeah because isn't it the
truth she had even what she did she came
for repentance you see the thing here is
what i the issue that i have with these
yeah
is let me but let me just before you go
on that uh because there's uh let's
seduce so she came and she did the most
horrific things god's mercy is above
that right he could as long as you don't
commit shirk
yeah and then but why it would be why
would the one who doesn't pray be worse
because that person is not asking for
toba that word is not connected to god
you see that first of all i have to go
after this
you know
you see not praying is a sin
doing what she did is a sin yeah
now con you know it's it's ideally as we
you know we approach ramadan here some
people come into that don't fast you
don't pray
so he doesn't pray
you know throughout the year and the
person would come why are you fasting
he said why let him fast
listen not fasting is a sin not praying
is a sin so not because you're doing
this one that you should go and
you know let him a lot of people come
back to allah because of fasting you
know maybe he is going to go to the
masjid and get the the thing that we
have once we quote these
that you know you're you're
you're really bringing down you have
i can tell you right now a lot of hadith
yes a lot of opinions of the scholars
regarding not praying
not praying imagine you need to
understand that the view of el hanabila
you know the the
the question regarding uh the person who
does not pray whether he is a kafir or
not
you know the view of alhanabila a school
of thought in islam
and so forth
and his students that even a person who
does not pray out of
laziness is a cafe
of course the other
jurors know
you know as long as he is not rejecting
you know the command of allah
people still that person still you know
has a chance he's a pheasa basically
that's the but this is a very danger and
and they have evidence they they do have
evidence rasulullah saw him in a
straightforward hadith he says that the
the line between
polytheism disbelief
and islam is
allah that you don't pray
you have humongous
eloquent texts stories we have stories
that can be shared about not praying
and and the danger of that but you don't
have to fabricate you know
something you know so this i think this
one was uh that i heard i heard from one
when um one shaykh this was uh and i and
i always said i i'm the type of person i
wanna
i want i want the authentic i couldn't
find it listen and it was a israeli
listen listen uh i could be wrong and it
it can be somewhere i mean i'm not
claiming that i know every little yeah
but
stuff like that even if that can't from
the context you would know you know
people who are into that field yeah with
no
you know it's like somebody comes and
says if you say
seven times
seventy thousand birds will be saying
this and
right away from that you see islam is
not a mystic kind of yeah
and this is what people i mean because
uh
people get turned off a lot of these
esoteric strange things you know but
islam is authentic it's preserved and
it's text is authentic it's religion
special yeah authenticity
you can sing the blues yeah
show me you know that's what i like
about missouri show me state
you shouldn't be listening to me if i
don't show evidence for what i'm saying
you shouldn't
and i you know a lot of the people when
they speak they speak
as if they you know no you know one of
my first teachers uh he was really
keen on stressing his point what's the
basis
you see your job you know if you really
want to be in the field of dawah yeah
eddie
connect the people with allah and his
messenger get out of the picture
don't call people to yourself yes
connect them
look our predecessor what they say
the knowledge of this religion call
allah
you connect the people with that
generation back
and get off the picture don't call
people to you yes who are you
i'm striving like anyone else since
we're talking about dawah before we get
into a couple more things tell us now
dr kareem abuzaid
specialist and prefers to be called
student of knowledge but you're a
specialist in this field you actually
had and
you were for several years answering
many of these questions on
let's talk about it yeah we i used to
have a show yeah so you're someone who
um
specializes in answering these type of
questions nowadays i don't know if
you're familiar and with the
ultimate fighting championships uh some
of these sports that are out there
combat where people
uh it's called mixed martial arts where
you have you got the boxing kickboxing
and wrestling all this together
now there is a a for a more elaborate
response we have one of your colleagues
i believe uh dr hatim
and then go to the deanshow.com where he
talks about uh boxing hitting in the
face and this and the
the the
what is islam just in a nutshell this is
something that would be
if someone asks you if they can get
involved in a sport like this
the i don't know he has he he has a
whole detailed you know response they
can go to that but let's assume not to
put you on the spot someone's already in
it they're already in it okay so you're
not authorizing that someone can do it
but someone is already in it they're
muslim they're already in it you're not
gonna get them out okay
uh so you're not gonna and then some
people out weigh like the the
the um lesser of two evils right let's
say someone was um you had actually had
an imam son right he couldn't get him
off the street you know what i mean and
this is the only way to save him right
right to save this kid so he got
involved in these sports
my point what i'm trying to say and
again for elaborate before someone gets
in into this they can go and they can
see your colleague it's on the dean's
show.com just put boxing or something
but now someone has the spotlight and
we're talking about dawah
when somebody is up in that area and
millions of people
are shining
on them watching them
what responsibility
uh now you're there you log okay you
want it allah gave you a chance to go
ahead what are you gonna do with it now
what responsibility should a muslim have
these are muslim you know what i mean to
go ahead and use this platform for dawah
what do you think about that i i really
don't know what uh
brother
hatim said you know it's not allowed
he's it's not yeah about it but
he said it's not basically it's not
allowed i'm gonna i don't know what you
yeah
i'm gonna speak your language yes
you know that that show that you put for
people
how will it sound
if you stand in front of this world who
praised you so much yeah
and say
i'm sorry
i have to retire because my religion
this allows me to do this
imagine this message that you give
you know
against that message of muslims being
barbarian you know and
imagine
why not do that
and you know when torah if you leave
something for the sake of allah
allah will replace it with something
much better for you
no compromise in this because you have a
crystal clear text
about it punching in the face and
the the aggressiveness of this is proper
english
you know the aggression and
so
no
okay so we got that out of the way
that's that would it's better to even if
you're in it to retire from it because
yeah this is something that would not be
permitted based on
what you said the hadith
he mentions reciprocating the harm this
right yeah and there's a bunch of again
for more elaborate uh academic you know
answer a
um
you can go to the dean show and watch it
but now
until the person
this is a great thing okay what you just
said but now i see a lot of
while a person is there maybe they're
not there yet to do that right
what advice do you give them until they
do that right instead of you know um
signing out of people signing autographs
little things that i see that people can
do like where they can go ahead and send
a nice message you know
because what is you know what i you know
um
i'll give you an example when someone
comes to take a picture with me say why
i can either be rude and you know
or not want to take a picture and then
people are going to be thinking i'm
stuck up arrogant but i say
i take a
a message out purpose of life ever
wonder so now there's dao in the
pictures in the autograph someone asked
you right and you put always remember
god always remember allah you follow me
muhammad ali what he used to do was he
used to have brochures as jesus god
and he would sign those and give them
out right
so little things like that that people
can do to share while they're doing this
what is your advice on that nobody you
get what i'm saying listen
because there's a lot of maybe there's a
lot of these [ __ ] a lot of these people
out there
exactly what they're saying yeah
and again you're going in circles
and i was going to bring you back to the
center of the circle yeah isla you know
you know have you ever been on board i
fly a lot so that's why you ever heard
the the flight attendant making that
announcement that in case of emergency
something is gonna drop from uh you know
for the blood for the uh yeah the oxygen
make sure you help yourself first
even if you have a child sitting next to
you yes don't help that child
help yourself first
listen i am in the business of saving
myself
and hopefully my family yes that's my
priority
now
i'm not going to become a bridge
where people go to paradise go to
guidance and then at the end i will be
thrown into hell
don't do that yeah don't burn yourself
in order follow your religion first the
religion bans you from doing this submit
to allah
give up
this for the sake of allah and if allah
wills he will use you in other
venues in other means to
propagate and promote islam but don't
burn yourself in order to save others
nobody said that
leave it at that gotcha okay so now
going back to qatar right person says
look i'm born in a christian family
other person is born in a buddhist
family that's what god destined
for me to be on the religion of my
family
what do you say to that well you don't
know what got destined
you know do you know what god wrote for
you
no
you don't
you know
anyone who uses the qatar
the the predestination
as a justification for not following the
truth
or indulging into sinning
just tell him one statement which is
actually a verse
in surat
do you have access to what is written in
the preserved tablet
or did allah give you a covenant
you don't know what allah wrote for you
now
yes
you were born into that religion
allah will send someone that can be
eddie that can be kareem that can be
ahmed that can be maryam can be fatima
can be hala whoever it is
to show you the path to islam
you still have a choice yes yes
so this um when we say qatar you have
obviously five pillars of islam you know
accepting there's nothing worthy of
worship so the creator that happens in
earth praying five times a day the
fasting during the month of ramadan
paying the the poor dude text the zakat
and the hajj then the six
uh articles of
of faith and belief in one god the
angels the books the messengers
um the
day of judgment and
this
is what do you advice do you have for
people who
struggle with this they say they they
struggle with this you know
lack of motivation saying well at the
end
you know god has determined where i'm
going to be you know and they don't move
because of of this color they they they
can't wrap their mind around it so this
kind of paralyzes them i always tell
that story you know
first of all
you know
a clear warning
regarding the subject
and i'll come back to the story
that don't indulge into it
if you don't know it
because it can be very confusing to some
muslims yeah
um is that statement where ali
said this is one of the the secrets of
allah is that authentic yeah
yeah
is the secret of allah and his creation
yes
and al-qaeda is one of the subjects
which is very sensitive why again
because it is associated with the names
and the attributes of allah
and you have to be very careful
we were warned against indulging into a
conversation that leads a person to
question
and doubt
but there is a minimum because
you quoted the six articles of faith
there is a minimum that every single
muslim must know
about
in order to develop iman
you see
again islam is not a mystic religion
where you sit and say okay i'm going to
believe in this how i'm going to do it
so you must read yes
what
qatar
has four levels
you must believe that
level number one you must believe
that allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala knew
everything that happened in the past
he knows everything that is happening
right now as we speak
detailed
in details he's not ignorant of anything
in details if a leaf falls down
everything
and he knows everything which will
happen in the future he doesn't have to
read a book no
even the hypothetical
is the question what if he knows it yeah
because we got to read books to learn
allah knows everything so this is
level number one you must learn that
that's why the subject is related to the
attributes the attribute of knowledge
absolute knowledge
[Music]
don't you know that allah knows what's
in the heavens and what's in the earth
indeed this is all written in a book
so the second attribute that allah
committed that knowledge into what
into a book called
the preserved tablet
which is above the throne and no one has
access
no one knows what's in that book
no one
learn
yes not a sent messenger nor abroad by a
nearby angel like jibril mikhail srafil
and so forth
so this is true
that's the minimum that you need to know
three erada the will
allah subhanahu wa
for what he knew
and what he wrote
to come into existence
to happen
to happen
look at this now
after that allah created us to make it
happen
allah created us to make it happen so
look at these four attributes knowledge
creation
will
i'm sorry knowledge riding
will creation divine world creation
fall
you must believe that
so everything that happens happens for a
reason
now
we use the qatar
they believe in the divine destiny
to comfort ourselves
regarding calamities
or things that happen to you that
you had no control over
you understand
but we do not use the qatar they believe
in the qatar to justify
our shortcoming
our laziness
or our sinning
you're getting that yes you see so we
use qatar and that's where faith becomes
handy
when you go through calamities
whether in your own
self
death
loss of wealth loss of children
except it's written in a book before it
came the four we go back to the four
allah knew it wrote it willed it so it's
a mercy now for you permitted it to
happen yeah
allah and i'll come back to this point
primarily to have it
because you know it's from allah yeah so
there must be a good wisdom behind it so
the brother extended his family now
and he went on and the sister is
struggling with that yes it's it's it's
for a wisdom it's a wisdom it's always
i'll come to this yeah i'll come to this
in in in a moment
so i just want to focus on this point so
we use the qatar to find comforts
and if something befalling you
something wrong happened to you
don't say
if i would have done this this would not
have happened
to question allah his wisdom
why didn't i do this
why didn't i save my son why didn't i
save my wealth why did i make the right
business decision
rather say
allah has ordained
and whatever he ordained came to pass
so again the point i'm trying to make we
use the qatar to find comfort pertaining
to
calamities
hardships trials and tribulations
that's it
because you trust allah is wisdom that
there must be a wisdom behind and i will
come to this point
but we do not use qatar
to justify a sin
you are indulged in involved in as we
speak or a sin
that you want to do in the future
here is the story that i wanted to tell
then
i sidetracked
i used to be an imam in
washington dc and maryland before going
to colorado
so this brother came and he wanted to do
counseling because of his wife and so
forth
so i said to him brother you know
this is years back actually i was like
still starting in knowledge i was
startup yeah
come after us inshaallah let's pray
and then i'll sit with you
so we prayed asar and i led the salah
and i looked at the congregation behind
me i didn't see him so i said to myself
let me go to the office do some
paperwork and hopefully you know he will
show up if he shows up khalas will sit
if not then i'll go home knock knock
knock here here salaam alaikum
i'm here for counseling so i assume that
he did not pray answers
so i said to him brother why didn't you
go make wudu in sha allah and pray asar
and i'll wait for you
here is the
allah here is what he said quote allah
doesn't want me to pray
this profound statement he's making
right away you tell that person do you
know what allah wanted for you yeah
that's exactly what it
is
so he's using this is what we call i'm
sorry i i but
this is what we call a section islam
called jebri yeah fatalist
you know during the time of
a man's tool and he is to establish the
criminal punishment in him
he said yes
he can't establish the criminal
punishment on me because i stole because
i stole
it was my qatar to steal
and omar said i will execute the penal
puni the
the criminal punishment of a thief on
you because because of qadhari
quite frankly at this time i was not
very well versed in the subject
so i again that subject is a very
sensitive and
if if you go into the subject you must
have the biddles you know like somebody
goes with a boot in in in in the sea if
you don't have the right to come back
you get in trouble yeah you got to be
but subhan allah allah subhanahu wa has
guided me to make that statement
which later on i found out was deep
i said to him why don't you stand up and
go to
the bathroom and make wudu and pray asar
and say the same statement that allah
wants me to pray
that's pro even profounder yeah it's the
same thing yeah
and this is what is what's in the quran
you said why don't you go and make wudhu
and pray and pray allah wants me to
allah wants me to pray now
because you don't know what allah wrote
for me for you to begin with do you know
what allah wrote for you
the scholars they say yes
he is using the unknown as an evidence
he doesn't know it meanwhile he is
rejecting the knowing that he allah sent
you a messenger telling you that you
should pray in order to be happy in this
world not depressed in order to go to
jannah in the hereafter so which one
should you take clear evidence or your
desires knowing evidence you have a
known evidence no clear evidence and and
so you reject that and you use what your
desires
well the desire is debates but you're
using unknown you don't know what allah
wrote for you yes
again we go back to the but when we when
we debate with fatalists
when you talk to them about that stuff
they always use a very interesting
hadith
a conversation that happened between
adam alaihissalam and prophet moses and
this is not israelites this is authentic
right because the prophet told us about
when they met the night of the ascension
adam musa met adam
and he immediately said to anta adam you
are adam our father
you are the one who got us out of the
garden
because eating off the tree
so adam looked at his grandson with a
with wisdom
you are my grandson
allah wrote the torah for you giving you
the torah didn't you read in the torah
that this was written upon me
pay attention here so that the father is
the people who believe in that sect they
tell you
adam is using the qatar as what
a justification for his mistake mistake
and imagine at the end of this hadith
the prophet sallam actually made a very
interesting statement for
meaning what the prophet is saying three
times he said three times that adam
won the debate
adam made a
point ah come to me now i tell you yes
you may use the qatar
as a justification regarding something
in the past that you repented from
because everything is qatar
allah permitted it to happen yes
you know like you say
like i was you know
you know when i was young you know
teenager
i was doing this
me that i i end up drinking or i end up
doing this haram stuff but alhamdulillah
repented alhamdulillah
so using it what not being boastful
about it but you're trying to let people
know that he can be a sinner but
but you cannot use the qatar regarding a
sin that you're committing now
or a sin that you're planning to commit
in the future yes
are you getting this absolutely yeah now
let's come to the issue
of
allah willing
certain things that we don't like
that allah knew
wrote
willed it and he actually permitted it
to happen
you see out of respect we do not
attribute evil to
allah that is why when we say believing
in al-qaeda
believing in al-qaeda
the good of it and what we consider to
be evil
the scholars they say we have two types
of evil
mutlaq
absolute evil what does it mean sharon
would love
zero
goodness will come out of it
and there is another type of evil that
they call
the best way to translate this in
english purposeful evil
what does it mean
you see it evil
but the end result of it will be good
it has some purpose behind it there is a
purpose behind it purposefully allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will never permit
the first time to take place in earth
absolutely not
no way
only human can do absolute evil that you
you go and do something that but allah
knows never will never permit
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
invited us
to read every friday a chapter called
the cafe
in that chapter there is a story out
there if you reflect upon it it explains
this
it sends that message to you
what story
you get two individuals both of them are
sent by allah
but with one difference
one of them
sees with the eye of divine tomorrow and
the other one is judging what he sees
based on now
you understand
they met together
they got on the ship
they didn't have money
this masakeen poor people giving them a
free ride
musa is sitting on the ship
and he sees
taking a tool and he's
digging a hole in the ship
for musa because he's judging the
situation now that's absolute evil
these guys giving us a free ride and
they are keen what are you doing
but you see al khadr has an extension to
what
allah revealed to him
why he should do this
he's got the whole picture yes
and that's why
look at the word saber
how many times it's repeated in the in
that segment of the sword
having i told you that you're not going
to be patient with me
and that's the issue that that's why
when we're when we're inflected with a
calamity we're supposed to do what right
away
be patient be patient allah will show
you the purpose later on that is why the
prophet salallahu salaam described
wasab
muslim sub is light why because of your
passion allah will make you see the
wisdom
so they get off the ship look at this
calamity now
they are walking together and here is
some sri lanka if you like
it
goes and he grabs
a little boy under the age of puberty
and he separates his head from his body
this is absolute evil
this is
i mean
one of them
you know we believe as muslims that
children who die before the age of
puberty are what
they go to jannah there is actually a
consensus about this
there's actually a debate amongst the
theologians you know that
the scholars who who teach the rasool
the fundamentals of the religion
regarding
the children of the mushriks
if they die before the age of puberty
there is a question mark that they could
go to jannah too because they are not
accountable because accountability in
islam kicks off when when you're puberty
at puberty but we believe as muslims
that but he cannot identify you cannot
point at this child and say he's going
to gender you can't say that
you have to do it strictly without yani
identifying so do you consider
do we consider him a prophet he's a
prophet of allah and i know some people
do like this
is come on get get alive he said
i did not do this on my own
i was receiving commands from allah who
receives command from allah but a
prophet
you see
come on i mean
i understand people are gonna you know
some brothers are gonna resent me for
saying that but listen i love you and
you know that's the way it is
shahid
they got off the ship
well i want to tell you something
eddie
if you want to name the greatest
calamity
that a person can be inflicted with is
the loss of your son or daughter
allah is telling you even in this one
there is goodness
that allah would send the angel to
someone who lost his son
what is my slave is saying
europe is saying alhamdulillah
so allah will say abdi my slave
fell
i took a piece of his liver
built for my slave a house in jannah and
call it the house of
praise house
it's a great calamity allah is telling
you even in this one there is goodness
so musa because he's judging now what al
hidra did in the eye of
divine tomorrow but again
we go back to these brothers
doesn't know all the knowledge of the
unseen
allah gave certain people certain
bits and pieces of the knowledge because
they don't say that he knows everything
in the bad no no no no
the knower of the unseen he only gives
like our messenger
he was given some of the
unseen the signs of the hour and so
forth
he knows why he's doing this
but musa is judging it now for him this
is a absolute evil mutlaq you're killing
a baby a child
but later on look at this look at this
this child would he have grown past the
age of puberty he would become a
disbeliever
not only this he would have caused his
believing parents
to become disbelievers
what is the solution for this
for him to die before the age of puberty
goes to jannah
his parents to maintain
their iman not only this for their
patience
allah will replace them with a believing
child happy family at the end
exercising the servitude of patience is
mandatory
you accepting it no
later on you accepted no nobody said
that you have to accept it and be happy
about it don't don't walk around and oh
allah has taken my son i'm happy no
don't do that no no but patience
last
question before we conclude you know i
did a program
not too long ago
and we were answering a question with
the sheikh regarding
tarbia regarding children
and it's something where after this
program
it was specifically having to do with
teachers
using verbal sending verbal messages to
kids
that didn't empower them but it kind of
demoralized them their confidence their
self-esteem
and then it opened up a conversation
with people also coming out
and talking about how they also they
left islam at one point because they
remembered a particular teacher hitting
them or using some language with them
and then they
came back
and then even some imams that i spoke to
they also were talking about how this is
kind of like a silence
a
a secret an open secret that this is
something that needs to be talked about
it's something that people have
inherited from their country they're
they're they're doing these same methods
and
i've even heard someone mention
a
a certain person was telling me
i just one justification i'll see what
you're one is um
it's really crazy uh that you know when
the prophet saw some he got the
revelation that came to him he was
squeezed
i don't know if you ever heard this one
so people who do this type of method
they'll say well the prophet saws some
you know we're teaching quran so the
prophet saw before he got quran he was
squeezed very tight inflicted with some
pain so we have to inflict that was one
some people also talk about the hadith
with the prophet saw some said you're
um guide your children to pray at seven
and then discipline them by the by the
time they're eight oh no ten i'm sorry
so they'll use some of these these uh
hadith
so i wanted to continue on from there
some of yours on on what i've just said
and what do you have to say about it
first of all the uh you know i it was
amazing because i i i mean i'm
presenting right now the seerah of the
prophet saw
it's available online as well
it's called know your messenger and i
happen to be just presenting that scene
of the squeezing
and the wisdom behind it you know we got
this guy that crazy guy salman i think
he came up with that thing called
satanic verses
he's basically saying that these are
thoughts personal thoughts so the
squeezing here is to show you that you
have two entities
two individuals
interacting with one another
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
so it's not internal
uh
you know thoughts just to expel that
we'll come to the subject of of uh you
know command them to pray at the age of
uh seven and then at the age of ten go
ahead and and and punish them if they do
not do we'll we'll come to this for a
minute but let me begin by
the issue that can you use instead of
punish discipline same thing yeah
discipline yeah discipline the issue
that we have uh eddie with this subject
is it has nothing to do with that
actually these are weak
uh evidence
that are taken completely out of context
to justify something that is wrong
something that is to be corrected it has
to be corrected because this is wrong
this is absolutely wrong what's wrong
demoralizing
uh calling a student names and
and
i have to admit i used to be a teacher
at one stage of my life
i used to do this
and i realized that that this is wrong
you see
the problem with a lot of these teachers
give some examples of that you've heard
the problem with these teachers they
came from overseas
and all their asset
is the memorization of the quran
but they have not gone through any
curriculum
psychology
of of a child
a curriculum of of how to
teach
the
manners and the etiquettes of teaching
and they even do not use
the proper evidence
to teach them if you're going to if
you're going to say that you're
completely a religious guy you don't
want to go into that conventional kind
of
you know education
you know to become a teacher in america
you have to go through you have a you
have to have a teaching degree right
yeah you see they don't only
teach you what to teach they teach you
the psychology the the the interaction
with the child pedagogy yeah the mat we
don't go through this
so and now he goes after one or two
evidence
and taking them out of context to
justify what he's doing wrong or to
justify what i'm doing wrong maybe
meanwhile you have tons of evidence
that teaches you that you need to be
soft you need to be kind to the children
the prophet saws anna spent 10 years
with him
he didn't do that with him
one time he told him to do something he
did not do it he looked at him and he
smiled and he left
you understand
you have multiple evidence a lot of them
that show you that you have to be soft
you have to be kind i think
the point here
is
we are trying
to teach american children and
i'm sorry i'm making this exclusive to
americans
but let's say european children
in europe
or in america
using techniques
that were brought up with
back in the in the middle east
in a different time in a different place
so
we live in a different time in a
different place different environment
huh and we want to use techniques and
and and
that that were implemented
in a different time in a different place
that's exactly what the problem is and
all what we're after is
bringing out some
weak
taken out of context evidence in order
to justify this this is wrong
eddie you need to understand this
the teacher
can be a great
impact
on a child because he contributes to the
upbringing of the child like the parents
but at the same time
he can be a devastating
impact
on that child and you mentioned i know
of certain people who left islam because
of their teachers
because of something that they saw in
their teachers and i know some people
who love islam
because of their teachers
so
we need to reconsider
and i call upon the brothers
and the sisters who came from overseas
don
don't submit
to that
reality because it's wrong
it's wrong
please for the sake of allah we love you
you know we love you and we appreciate
you because you memorized the quran
and you're helping
the ummah
revive
this tradition
but you need to understand that there is
a lot that you do not know about tarbia
there is a lot that you do not know
about teachings
and you need to consider maybe if if you
are not willing to take a class is to
listen to the advice
advise us when we teach people when we
try to convey the message convey it with
kindness
softness
you should not put down the person you
should not do that you should actually
encourage them to do that yes punishment
would rather use the word discipline i
i'm okay with that too discipline in
islam is
an element there is no question about
allah created jannah
heaven and
hell yes but
once it comes you see this is a an
everlasting eternal
you know punishment or eternal reward
this is after you conclude your mission
but we're talking about children
who are going through the age of tarbear
you know what terbia is that you try to
modify change their pattern of behavior
now what works
if calling them names
bullying them as a teacher bullying them
bullying them i'm sorry the word is
will put them down demoralize them
make them resent it
will you do it no you shouldn't
shouldn't do it
you should do what helps them to change
to be better people
and i tell you with american kids
the lollipop
approach
works a lot yeah and and that's you know
i think these brothers also need to
realize
that the future of this ummah
is in these children
we're waiting for you know a child to
come and help us out
don't kill them
execute that dream don't don't kill
these kids don't put them down
we need kids out there who will love
that this deen who love this this
religion who loved the quran who are
proud of and and
and they come out there and they say
we're muslims and and
we need that you know we're having
issues now eddie with with our children
they are leaving islam some of them some
of them they shy away from
even saying that they are muslims they
change their names to moan so this is
just another excuse another door yes
that opens that you're helping help him
love it yeah
you see the prophet
was the greatest teacher of the fossil
of course no one can attain his
but at least we need to
try
he made his companions love the calls
loved the cause yeah you as a teacher
you make them love the quran yeah you
make them love memorizing the quran
you make them enjoy the experience
it will make a difference in their lives
but don't tell me that you're trying to
you see it's knowing it's known if
somebody does something
you want from them
out of fear
the moment that fear is lifted they're
not going to do it
yeah
yes maybe he doesn't want to be called
the name maybe he doesn't want to be
pushed around
all right that's why he's going to go
let me rise because i don't want to hear
this teacher man i'm tired of this
teacher but the moment that he doesn't
feed you anymore it's over he's not
going to do it
but imagine doing it out of love
man i love the quran this teacher you
know when that when i memorize and even
if i make a mistake he explains it to me
and
it makes a difference eddie it's a whole
different thing yeah yeah
you were i want to say something you
were going to go back to i want to say
something yes
and allah is my witness
i used to do these wrong things
and i learned the hard way
and and that is why i'm calling about my
brothers who are in this field who have
not uh you know
you know
i'm telling you reconsider
reconsider
you know we all learn you know we're
human we make mistakes that's really
praiseworthy when someone can admit
to a mistake and come out and well i
didn't know i didn't know better yeah
you know you know when you do something
out of not knowing
even
even once it comes to this believing in
allah you're actually giving an
execution because of not knowing yeah
you were going to go back to the hadith
about prayer what were you going to say
about that
prayer yeah about seven
uh
guide them to prayer at seven and then
disciplined them by 10.
well were you going to comment on that
yeah well you said it it's discipline
yeah it's music what's the contest
because you know what the context is
someone you know what the context is i
heard i heard someone you know what the
context is please tell me
that he knows that you have that side
but you don't exercise it
you know that you have that authority
you know that you can punish
it's like ideally they say
he sees the stick hanging on the wall
but you never bring it down
is that authentic hadith about the
sticker well yeah there is uh hassan
yeah yeah but
shad is you don't bring it down
but he knows yeah and that takes
teachings you know that listen you know
don't mess around with me yeah but you
could convey this still that harshness
that toughness
in your character you could convey it in
a way that is decent
without humiliating demoralizing the
person
but at the same time if he's doing his
job if he's struggling if he's striving
you need to understand also the the
state of mind of your student if he's
trying
you know
if he's not doing it then you can show a
little bit of harshness and
yeah that's what is meant by it yeah
yeah when you look at i was uh taking
i'm taking our class on islamic island
university in pedagogy
education and kids and whatnot
education in general and when you dwell
into this it is profound how many
how many different
psychologists uh avenues there are you
know any studies and human behaviors but
someone says look all i need is quran
and sunnah
even quran and sunnah doesn't back you
doesn't back this up that's the point
i'm trying to make
even if you're going to dwell on quran
and sunnah i can sit out here and quote
to you
how rasulullah
treated imagine imagine this imagine
this rasulullah
is sitting in the middle of his campaign
i'll give you just one one pattern one
example i'm sorry
one example
with his companions
a young man approaches the prophet the
teacher
guess what he's asking
i want to commit adultery and you're
going to give me a permission
right here
that's a moment that you can seize to
beat this guy up to death and that's
actually some of the companions
attempted to do that
but that can be
a teaching moment yeah
oh leave him alone
or when the guy urinated in the masjid
yeah that's another one yeah
you know that's but you know
but this is this is a one that you know
come closer look at this teaching
moments here teaching moments
would you like someone to do this to
your mother
if you have a daughter
if you have a sister
if you have a and if you have material
maternal end
he could actually there is no point of
repeating this but he's teaching him
yeah
again
would you imagine someone coming to you
and doing this yeah so our dean doesn't
close the door to get that
that knowledge
where it can we use the hadith for the
prophet saw some had said that knowledge
is a lost treasure of the believer
wherever he can grab it so in these
areas now the teachers being taught how
to teach that's an art and of it's i
teach i mean i teach been teaching
martial arts for you know
over almost 20 years now and it i can
understand you know we also have uh
children there if we would
use any of these methods we'd be out of
business you follow me and there's art
in teaching it's an art you know what i
mean especially with children
the adults are different but now going
there's nothing where you're putting
yourself back you're actually moving
forward when you take a class
specific class three weeks month two
months no you're only going to grow
listen and shouldn't we be people if
we're people of quran and sunnah
shouldn't we be ready for change at any
time
to adjust our behavior to
to the right thing always whatever we're
right we're ready to modify to change
according to chronosync so if we've been
doing something for 20 years 30 years
it's not right i have to tell you the
truth comes to us
the western world excelled in this
they created
you know
rules
rule book yeah for a teacher you can do
do do not do
and if you actually trace these
are islamic
for each one of those i can give you
evidence from the quran and the sunnah
or incident that happened
so why not
why not adopt it why not
shaytan one time told abu hurairah
something
imagine shaytan told
us something about the story about
ayatul kursi before you go to sleep yes
some of the people may not be aware of
it
but
he said this to me he said he spoke the
truth this one is good take it from him
take it from him because it's the truth
even though he's not telling the truth
in in other areas but this one because
of the truth take the truth
take the truth even from
you know you understand yeah
i think my point is yeah so if the truth
is there where people are connoisseur we
take it
and we
grow from it we learn from it we become
better teachers when we come yeah
uh and the last thing is i mean because
a people
a person t
people
according to their position they're held
at certain levels right
so a policeman has a responsibility
uh
teacher and math has a certain response
now teacher of quran i mean this is our
teacher of islam
that's a whole new we look at doctors
have certain they take the hippocratic
oath do no harm you know the doctor but
now the quran teacher
the islamic teacher this is at a whole
nother level you have a golden
opportunity yeah
to impact this boy's life this girl's
life yeah i tell you golden opportunity
to have a place
in their lives
you can be a king without a crown in
their lives they can respect you
love you
even when your name is mentioned
after your death
they will they will invoke the mercy of
allah
yeah
and you can be a disgrace too
if your means for them to leave the
demon you can be
you know this is grace yeah may allah
protect us from that yeah
choose the right thing yes thank you
sheikh thank you shay we covered a lot
inshallah
you know come chicago and and and visit
with you eddie you're getting old man
i'm dying it should do something about
it
thank you guys for tuning in and
subscribe if you haven't already and
we're here
every week here on the dean show with a
new and exciting episode we'll see you
next time until then peace be with you
assalamu